The Voice has crowned a new winner after  weeks of intense competition it came  down to these four contestants vying for  the coveted title Barret Emily Anne  Jeffry and Jordan one of your lives is  about to change forever  Jeffrey Austin from Team Gwen finished  4th and Barrett Weber from Team Blake  placed third leaving it up to Emily Ann  Roberts on Team Blake and Jordan Smith  on Team Adam the winner of the voice is  Jordan Smith  the finale was packed with tons of  incredible entertainment Justin Bieber  blew the house down with a show-stopping  performance of his hit sorry  he started out slow is it's only now to  say sorry cause I'm missing more than  just your body and then kicked it into  high gear